you have in this film what i wish i i
had and i never have you have like
confidence and i'm just so wrapped when
i'm watching you not to creep out but
sorry you are no that's really nice i
think it the i think what is being
misconstrued as like poise is just
uh
at the start of of every take i just do
an anxiety kegel and i hold it
anxiety kegel made me laugh like make a
diamond just inside make a diamond god i
need to make more diamonds
i'm making like biscuits and pancakes
and all the doughy things
um i our we have a mutual friend robin
fredericks and you guys just did the
lost city yeah together which is the
channing tatum sandra bullock movie that
everybody's freaking out for just
yeah right yeah yeah is it do you think
it's a good movie because it looks good
i i think it's gonna suck
no i i'm so excited for it i'll check
i'm gonna check out the movie i guess
yeah it looks good i think actually the
caper
genre it's going to make a comeback
because cell phones pretty much
destroyed all storytelling like you just
pick up the phone and call that person
and tell them to get out of harm's way
yeah i mean it is like
amazing to watch how many movies like
an answering machine was like a plot
point like plot devices like that you
had to have an answering machine for
that to work and it had to be an
answering machine that like screened
yeah like you could listen to the room
like people are hearing it now i guess
that's like uh-oh you're accidentally on
speaker phone or something i don't know
think about that like you've got mail
would be so much lamer if like tom hanks
was like do you want to facetime you
know what i mean like
i would love to see you got mail but
it's like grindr ding
you got nails
yeah oh mail yeah
yeah that's good but one thing that
doesn't seem to um
sort of change too much as our obsession
with relationships
and together together
it's so rich and poignant about
friendship relationships intimacy
all of that
yeah i think you know
when i first read the script for it i
it seemed like it was going to be very
formulaic
like
older guy meets younger girl and then
this unconventional relationship like
goes the route that i was like ready to
roll my eyes out of my head into space
before but it like incorporates a lot of
those tropes and a lot of those
expectations
uh in a like a very subtle package all
right will you hit some headlines with
us patty yes okay great all right
all right patty listen to this
were you two questions were you two
aware that you can now wear a pair of
pants that seamlessly turn into a shoe
what
yeah well now you can just ask martha
stewart in style reports martha stepped
out in these brown leather pants that
are part legging part espadrille
we could call him a lespadrill if you
will
and this comes on the heels of the jute
which is of course the gene boot combo
worn by julia fox now okay are you in or
are you out
i feel
just that
you know if if bart simpson is allowed
for his skin and his hair to be one
thing then martha stewart can wear her
espadrille pants fair points
thank you
i did not when i heard martha stewart
was wearing this look i didn't know what
to picture and then i saw the picture
and i say this to you all the time
martha you're so hot so hot you're so
hot yeah i flirt with you
i make it uncomfortable
and these pants are just
chef's kiss yeah
would you wear them not a chance
i will not be wearing a jute
or oh my god a
lespadrill
or any of it anytime soon i would wear a
jute tomorrow if we had one or you
martha send me yours please
i would look good well patty you have
the next story okay well
best life talked to dating experts who
say there's one piece of clothing you
should never wear i don't know what this
is i'm nervous and excited never wear on
a first date um
fanny pack how dare you as you said how
dare you fanny pack scrunchy uh uggs uh
bonnet
i mean all of those i think you're
you're describing my type
what is it it's
a white
shirt
they say it's a magnet for dirt or
whatever you're trying to get from the
plate to your mouth so best to leave
that stressor at home
i don't agree you don't no
i i feel like a white shirt is a magnet
for chili any barbecue sauce if i'm
wearing it it's going to be on anyone
else spilling themselves you wear a
white shirt
that's why i wear patterns
well i like stain removal so i wish more
people would wear white t-shirts because
i would just and they get stains i'd get
all up in there and start fixing it i
think i really think that's like you
know a barometer for
the quality of the soul of the person
you're on a date with because
you know we're
almost we're going to be three years
into a pandemic soon and if someone
doesn't have like
stains or marinara sauce on their shirt
that's a red flag if someone's not fully
in a diaper
at this point three years into a
pandemic that's a red flag
i swear also it's like that taylor swift
lyric she's like you've got that
like slick back white t-shirt like red
classic lip there it the white t-shirt
is hot yeah don't stop wearing those
it's not but if it's stained it's not
right
[Music]
you